TODAY IN THE EASTERN DISTRICT OF
VIRGINIA MADE THIS POINT.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE HOUSE
OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED A BROAD
RESOLUTION TO CONDEMN
ANTI-SEMITISM, BUT DOESN’T CALL
OUT CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR.
THE FRESHMAN LAWMAKER HAS MADE
NO APOLOGIES FOR A SERIES OF
OFFENSIVE REMARKS.
COLLEAGUES AND OTHER RADICAL
FRESHMAN RASHIDA TLAIB DOUBLING
DOWN ON HER DEMAND TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT FROM.
>> I WILL BE JOINING ADVOCATES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY TO FILE
THE IMPEACHMENT...
MY GOD, WHAT IS...
RESOLUTION!
I’M SORRY!
IMPEACHMENT RESOLUTION TO START
THE PROCEEDINGS.
>> Laura: SOMETIMES WORDS LIKE
"RESOLUTION," THEY JUST...
AND ONE OF THEIR FRIENDS, LINDA
SARSOUR, SEEN ON CAPITOL HILL
IGNORING QUESTIONS ABOUT HER OWN
ANTI-SEMITISM BY A MUSLIM
REPORTER.
>> WAIT, WAIT --
>> CAN YOU TURN THE CAMERA OFF?
I KNOW WHAT YOU’RE DOING, I
DON’T APPRECIATE IT.
WHY ARE YOU BLOCKING THE DOOR?
YOU ARE, LIKE, BLOCKING THE --
OKAY.
>> WE JUST NEED --
>> YOU ARE BLOCKING THE DOOR.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
THAT REPORTER, AND SARA CARTER,
FOX NEWS REPORTED.
KUDOS TO YOU.
LOVE IT, LOVE IT, LOVE IT.
WHAT DIDN’T WE SEE IN THE VIDEO?
>> WHAT YOU SAW WAS THE MOST THE
MUSLIM SUPREMACIST INACTION ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THEY ACTED LIKE THEY OWN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, AND
THEY SORT OF DO RIGHT NOW.
THEY CAME TO THE FRONT DOOR OF
RASHIDA TO
TALIB’S OFFICE, AND WE AND THUS
A SWORD TURNED TO CAIR, THE
WOMAN STEPPED FORWARD WITH
ANOTHER MAN AND HE BECAME THE
BOUNCERS AT RASHIDA TLAIB’S
OFFICE.
LOBBYING IS FROM THE MUSLIM
ORGANIZATION BECAME THE
GATEKEEPERS.
>> Laura: EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW
THAT YOU ARE A MUSLIM WOMAN
YOURSELF.
>> I AM.
I HELPED FOUND AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED MUSLIM REFORM MOVEMENT.
WE ACCEPT THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
WE DON’T HATE JEWS, WE ARE
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN SECULAR
GOVERNANCE, WOMEN’S RIGHTS.
THE ABILITY FOR ELLA VOSS TO
LIVE, ASSIMILATE, COEXIST.
NOT ACT LIKE VICTIMS IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY.
>> Laura: SARA CARTER, THIS
HAS BEEN A DISTURBING PERIOD OF
TIME IN THIS COUNTRY REGARDING
ANTI-SEMITISM.
SEEING IT IN EUROPE, GOING TO
PLAY SOME SOUND IN A MOMENT.
HOW SERIOUS IS THIS FOR THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY?
THEY BRUSHED IT AWAY, EVERYTHING
IS ABOUT TRUMP.
THIS WOMAN SAYS THINGS ABOUT THE
LIGHTED STOMACH DIVIDED
ALLEGIANCE.
SOME CONGRESSWOMAN ACTS LIKE
IT’S
IT’S TRUMP’S FAULT?
>> IT’S BEYOND DISTURBING,
LAURA.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN THESE
DIVISIONS AND ASRA SAID IT
PERFECTLY.
I’VE TRAVELED THROUGHOUT THE
MIDDLE EAST.
THIS IS SAID MUSLIM
SUPREMACY.
WHO WON TODAY?
THE PEOPLE WHO WON TODAY ARE
CAIR AND THE EXTREMIST IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHO LOST?
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE LOST
COMPLETELY BECAUSE NOW WHO ARE
THEY GOING TO CONFRONT EVEN ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE ABOUT
ANTI-SEMITISM LIKE MIKE LOOK AT
WHAT THEY’VE DONE TODAY.
THEY REFUSED TO CALL A SPADE A
SPADE?
IT’S REALLY FRIGHTENING, WE CAN
BRING THIS TO THE TABLE BECAUSE
WE DO NOT HEAR ENOUGH FROM
REFORMERS.
>> Laura: MUSLIM WOMEN HAVE
THE POWER TO TAKE THIS WHOLE
THING BACK.
I TALK TO SO MANY FRIENDS --
SOME DO.
NOT LINDA SARSOUR.
>> NOT LINDA SARSOUR.
WHAT’S HAPPENED IS THE LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS HAVE DECIDED THEY ARE
THE POSTER GIRL.
>> Laura: WHY DO THEY -- WHY
IS LINDA SARSOUR DELIVERING THIS
NEW NIRVANA OF FEMINISM?
AND YOU COMPLAIN THAT THE
PEOPLE?
>> THEY DECIDED ABOUT A DECADE
AGO THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
BECOME THE VICTIMS.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
RASHIDA TLAIB WENT FROM BEING
THE BULLY TO BEING THE VICTIM.
THEY INSERTED THE ANTI-MUSLIM,
YOU KNOW, ISSUE INTO THIS
RESOLUTION WHEN IT WAS NOTHING
ABOUT THAT.
THEY MADE IT NUMBER ONE.
>> Laura: I’D LIKE TO SHOW
SOME IMAGES HERE OF WHAT EUROPE
IS DEALING WITH.
AT THE BIG CARNIVAL IN BELGIUM,
THIS IS ON TUESDAY I BELIEVE,
THIS IS A PARADE FLOAT.
OKAY?
AND BELGIUM IS NOW IN MANY
PLACES MAJORITY MUSLIM AND
THERE’S A BIG ISLAMIST MOVEMENT
IN BELGIUM.
THESE ARE PICTURES OF PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY WHO LOOKS JEWISH.
THERE ARE BAGS OF MONEY.
THIS MADE THE ROUNDS ON A LOT OF
ISLAMIST WEBSITES.
WE GOT THEM GOOD.
THIS IS HAPPENING WITH THE
LABOUR PARTY IN BRITAIN.
LET’S PLAY THIS NEXT SOUND BITE.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE
THE DAY WHEN JEWISH PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR FUTURE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I CANNOT REMAIN IN A PARTY
THAT I HAVE TODAY COME TO THE
SICKENING CONCLUSION THAT IS
INSTITUTIONALLY ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> Laura: MOVEMENTS BY OTHER
MUSLIMS IN BRITAIN AGAINST GAY
CITIZENS, DISTURBING IMAGES
WE’VE SEEN TODAY?
>> THESE ARE HORRIFIC IMAGES AND
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS TIME.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, LAURA,
THERE’S A DOCUMENT HE I HELPED
WORKED ON, IT’S CALLED "NEVER
AGAIN IS NOW."
IT WAS ABOUT TO GO JEWISH WOMEN
THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE OF
THAT LITERALLY LEFT AMSTERDAM TO
WHAT’S HAPPENING OVER THERE IN
EUROPE.
ANTI-SEMITISM IS EXTREME.
WE ARE SEEING IT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE TO CALL IT OUT.
WE CANNOT BE AFRAID BUT WE
CANNOT COWER DOWN TO IT WE HAVE
TO TALK FOR MUSLIM WOMEN WHO DO
NOT SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF
RADICALISM.
>> WHAT’S HAPPENING IS OUR
RELIGION HAS BEEN TAKEN OVER BY
EXTREMISTS.
17 YEARS AGO, IT WAS MY
COLLEAGUE DANIEL PEARL WHO WAS
MURDERED, HIS LAST WORDS, "I AM
A JEW, MY MOTHER IS A JEW."
HIS FATHER CALLED ME.
HE WROTE IT DOWN.
"I AM DEVASTATED.